foreign
let's go out to Edmonton Canada and talk
to Elaine what's up Elaine
um the sky
well well played Elaine well played I
hope that felt good
what's up what's up um well
um so my husband recently had a
psychotic break ended up in a
mental facility for a couple weeks
um he's now out how do I help him work
through some of the craziness of that
time and how do you I and our kids deal
with what happened yeah it's scary tell
me about it what happened
um
okay take a breath take a breath you're
all good
did it happen in your home
um
hold on I just want to acknowledge for
everybody if you've never been around
this if you never
um
seen somebody you care about
have a psychotic break or if you've
never been with somebody it's terrifying
right it's like out of a movie
scary scary scary stuff and you see the
person that you love and care about
right in front of you and they are gone
and it is scary right
yeah like
um
one of the nurses in the first second
hospital we went to
um actually you just can't make this
stuff up like a discount
um hey do me a favor Elaine you talk
directly into the phone for me okay
that's okay that's good yeah I know I
anyways um so yeah so he there's been a
lot of uh stressors over the last
few years but particularly in the last
couple months
um
and so like I would say it was brought
on by lack of sleep you talk about how
important sleep is I cannot stress bad
enough
um
in the end he was
sleeping Maybe
between one and a half to three hours a
night living on caffeine and energy
drinks
um not a good thing yeah
yeah that's tough for your body to
handle um
yeah and
you know so give a little bit
anyone
um got another job in 22. he ended up
getting laid off from that one in
January of 23 and had just started a new
job in March and it was
um it was a good job but very very
stressful right he enjoyed it but like I
said there was a lot of stress around it
um and that was just one of multiple
things and Canada has been particularly
difficult over the last few years right
yeah we won't even go there
here's like I I
um some psychotic breaks are are brought
on by like a schizophrenic diagnostic
right it's not the diagnosis it does it
but you have a schizophrenic mind
um or you've got some
some
alterations in your neurochemistry in
your brain right other psychotic breaks
are brought on by you don't sleep for
two months and you live off you know uh
adenosine antagonist you live off
caffeine and it makes you
um it Alters the reality of your brain
right and one day you wake up and it's
you're you've to
an ugly way of saying is that you
snapped right and your body checks out
it loses touch with reality over time
and so there's and there's a long
Spectrum in between that but what's
important is also there's a context
there is an and there's a ecosystem
where this is all taking place and we we
often forget that right it's like the
couple who calls or the the mom who
calls and says
um my marriage is falling apart and then
they tell me they have four kids under
the age of seven well it's like well
it's not your marriage and flying apart
your house is insane and so being a
candidate over the last three years has
been really really hard and if you are
listening to this going what I don't
know anything about that just go back
and check it out there's been all this
government Clash if you think California
is bad what they what can't candidates
had to endure has been Madness and you
put that on top of a bunch of job loss
on top of on top of on top of and now
you get a recipe right for yeah you lose
your husband so what when he went to the
psych ward staying at Award for two
weeks tells me there was some pretty
significant things going on that wasn't
just a three-day get some sleep and get
some food in you and
let's get you uh like a
uh a treatment plan at home what was
going on
last week before but of course we've
never been through this before
um we've been married almost 36 years so
it's not like
you know I didn't know him or anything
um
and so yeah the last week things started
getting very odd very weird and then he
went to on the weekend it was
things started really going off the
rails he kind of lost it on me which in
a way that isn't normal for him
whatsoever
um but when he got when he got when he
got to the hospital did they give him a
diagnosis of anything
well no see he left work early on uh on
the Monday and then he was talking to me
on the phone and then he kind of went
off the grid we had no idea where he was
um eventually he
was
climbing on a Ledge and stuff in a car
wash and so they called 9-1-1 and the
cops and he had no ID on him he got to
the hospital and I'm looking all over
for him I thought I knew where he'd gone
but he hadn't got there to this remote
place where he wanted just some time
alone
um
and
so he was in the hospital for about two
hours I think before I got a call
um
and then when I got there he had been
sedated and when he
came to he was mostly himself like not
100 obviously
um the doctor came in talked to him for
a bit
okay originally they said they were
going to have us like eval done and then
he released him to me
um because he was doing so well
the moment he said they were going to
release him he started going off a
little bit
um
thought we went home
and you know knowing that sleep is an
issue he went to sleep and then
um this sounds really odd but he'd been
walking around infield for like three
hours before that and so just as he went
to sleep discovered some ticks and so
like the insect okay and so started
dealing with that and of course then he
was woke up and
um
he started panicking it's not safe it's
not safe can't be here it's not safe and
our one son lives to just
we have an acreage but we're on the edge
of town
and our son lives basically a couple
doors down and he took off running and
went to his house so ultimately he was
put back in the hospital for an Extended
Stay did they give him a diagnosis of
bipolar disorder of schizophrenia it
would be a strange three minutes late
but
they ultimately just said he needed some
sleep he burned himself out completely
just detached from reality for a while
they did toss around bipolar a little
bit but
um
it doesn't really stick the diagnosis
because it's not like going back right
so tell me tell me I'm trying to get to
how I can help you now so when they
discharged him what did they tell you
well
very difficult
um did he not sign a release
he signed a release but I don't think it
says in there anything about
bipolar
um well well so here's here's step one
okay
if if he is on the same page with you is
he on the same page with you
yeah okay he needs to contact his mental
health provider the doctors who are with
him and I don't know how Canada's system
works they would have given you a social
worker here in the states to help you
navigate everything so whenever one of
my students would go into a psych ward I
would go sit the first person I would
talk to is the social worker who helps
them navigate all the different doctors
and people coming in and out and
have him sign a release that says I need
you to tell my wife everything
that you found and to walk her through
what my next steps can be so she can be
and here's the magic word she can be an
advocate for me
and yeah I I did was able to talk with a
social worker involved but when I would
start asking some of the more medical
side of things uh she wasn't as clear as
what I could have hoped for so he did
sign a release when he was there so that
I could get information and all those
fun as well okay um so I would re I
would re-establish a meeting with her
now that he's been home for a little bit
and ask her some very pointed questions
very direct
um how many hours a night should he
sleep should he have access to the
internet is is caffeine completely off
the table it like
make them
with as kind as you can be make them
give you a Outpatient Treatment protocol
and that's the magic words Outpatient
Treatment protocol you are his Advocate
you're walking alongside him and they
might say he needs to go see a counselor
he's had a lot of job loss which is very
tough he's had a very tough run of it in
the last few years
um and so what we're going to do is the
first thing we're gonna do is we're
going to come up with the plan
the second thing is both you and him
have to recognize
the Free Fall Terror that is losing
control of your own body
it's scary to see that in yourself to
think I did what I did all those things
and the police are describing where they
got you and you have no memory of that
you don't know what you're talking about
um or he has a little bit of a memory
and it terrifies him and then for you
he's your rock he's the guy
and if he can suddenly find himself
climbing on top of a car wash and not
know how he got there
the question you're suddenly the ice I
mean the sidewalk you walk on it becomes
very thin eyes right it's it's hard to
put your foot down I don't want to set
him off I don't want to do the wrong
thing what do I say what do I do yeah
see what I'm saying is that does that
sound right
yeah absolutely yeah so if you have this
plan together
the second step is y'all build a new
marriage
how long 36 years in is that what you
said
in a couple weeks yeah congrats this is
a perfect time
now you can
build something completely new with the
knowledge that hey man like you found
out how far you can be pushed and we
found it I'm glad we're grateful that we
know this who are we going to become now
and you you might become people who turn
the TV off at 4 P.M and y'all just sit
on the front porch and talk to each
other and play cards and whatever you
might become people who take walks every
day and y'all are both in bed with the
lights out
at nine o'clock and you used to never be
the used to be out dancing well this is
a new thing we're building now does that
make do you see what I'm saying and let
give him a Content we're a couple who
every night we check in with each other
how are you feeling today what are you
thinking today you just give each other
a few minutes of space to talk
so normally the things that are highly
highly therapy Therapeutics kind of a
dramatic word
are healing at home after these moments
are things like skin to skin contact
things like I Want to Hold Your Hand for
um 30 seconds every morning and I'm
Gonna Hold Your Hand 30 seconds when you
get home from work I just want to hold
you can I just hug you for 30 seconds
and we'll count it out
the reason I'm hesitating to give you
anything like that is I that might be
what sets off his psychosis and so
without looking at the doctor's report
it's I don't want to give you a bunch of
things to do
I think the key will be him Having the
courage to tell you what he needs on a
given day and you having The Bravery
courage to listen to him and then to
love him and here's the hard part
you tell him what you need don't treat
him with a glass slipper do the opposite
give him some purpose and a role inside
that house and it will anchor him see
what I'm saying
and that's hard right now it's very hard
because you you wanna you wanna touch
everything with a velvet glove right you
want to be very careful not to set
anything off and if I just say the wrong
thing or move the wrong thing
and what that does is that puts his body
back on high alert because the one
anchor he's got is you and you're acting
different you're acting scared and
anxious and and so it just becomes this
this repeating cycle here
whereas you say hey I love you and and
when you take the trash out can you help
me out
I can be such a gift
see what I'm saying yeah like right now
like we we've had some of those
discussions you know where I've told
them like I'm on high alert for him
right because
I don't ever want to go down this path
again he doesn't want to go down this
path again
um it was pretty traumatic his stay in
there that's right um
terrifying in there yes
yeah like as he says it's a very dark
place yes it's a scary Darkness yes it
is it is and
you know there's
there's good
um in terms of you know him
understanding
more being more compassionate toward
people who are dealing with stuff like
that yeah but that's all external he
needs to be very compassionate with him
yeah and I think he's finally getting
there to where he is being more
open with himself and and you know I've
listened to your show for quite a while
and you talk about you know
asking your spouse what do you need from
me and I have asked that over and over
and he often says I don't know I don't
know I don't know
um
and I've noticed he's starting to be
able to say those things this is what I
need right now and so let me say this
and this is for you and for everybody
and that's awesome and you kept in here
here's an important thing you kept
showing up and you kept showing up and
you kept showing up
most people will say what do you need
today I don't know man I don't know hey
how can I love you today I don't know
and then they never ask again and that's
not you you kept showing up you kept
showing up you kept showing up and
eventually
when he realized oh I need a lot you
were there because you had laid up so
you laid it like a brick road that he
could walk on
also if the question what do you need
what do you need after a week after two
weeks
if they don't have an answer to that
maybe ask a different question
put your hand on his chest
and say where are you where are you
tense today
where are you anxious today is it your
shoulders is it in your chest is it in
your forearms like where is it today is
it on your feet
and tell him where it is on you and
here's what we're doing we're getting to
the base layer because sometimes uh and
I'm guilty of this sometimes we turn
um what do you need today what do you
need today in a transaction of activity
what do you need today I need this this
and this all right I'll do those three
things what do you need today I need
this this and this
all that is great but that sits that's
not the that's not the base layer that
sits on top of
I see you
and I'm with you
and I'm here for you
and those three things are so grounding
and it makes it very challenging for a
body to be in chaos when it is connected
with other people in that rooted way
whoo
and so it may be what do you need to do
what do you need today what do you need
today Bam
where are you so maybe you shift the
question where are you scared today what
are you scared about today
what do you really give me one thing you
got to give me one thing you're really
excited about today
what is one
hot romantic thing we can do today you
get one and I get one what is one
physical activity we can do today like
begin to Branch it out a little bit and
give him some
um some cues there but all this let's be
clear all of this is going to stem from
all these activities at home are going
to stem from you going back to the the
social worker
and really pressing on an outpatient
treatment plan
what based on y'all's expertise all
these doctors and all these tests and
two weeks in a psych ward well I don't
know how it is in Canada in the US would
be very expensive because there would be
a million different
um professionals that came in and out of
there
um
in y'all's expertise what are some
things that my husband needs
and you and him go away and build like
just dream together we got scared we got
scared whoa we made it we're here we're
back
here's my promise to you Elaine walking
around all tents
arms clinched hands clenched chest
clinched heart clinched
is a recipe for a very anxious house and
the goal here is to create a non-anxious
house okay non-anxious house
so um hang on the line here I'm going to
send you two decks of both of the
couples questions for humans and this is
just something you and him can do y'all
can make a ritual out of it and there's
52 cards in each deck this can get you
104 days and every day you can just sit
down and agree to do one card together
over uh I was gonna say over coffee
probably not over over warm warm water
and chamomile tea but y'all can have
this conversation together and it's and
again we are bridging back to one
another
we're going to follow this treatment
plan and we're going to figure out
creative ways to ask each other how can
I love you today
what does that look like what does it
feel like what does that taste like how
can I love you today he is really really
lucky to have you Elaine I know this is
a scary scary season
and I hate that for y'all if you've
never been to a psych ward folks it is a
scary dark place
and it's scary when you lose trust in
your own body it's scary when you lose
trust in the person who is the anchor of
the family
and this is the moment when you can you
can do one or two things you can walk
away from the collapse of the buildings
or y'all can exhale
and be sad and grieve it and then ask
yourselves what are we going to build
next